what's going on reject nation we are
almost done with all of us are dead
we are at episode 10 today if you can't
chomp into that like button also major
thanks to all those who have joined us on
our patreon page your support means a lot
full length watch vlogs for all of us are dead are
over there along with a bunch of other shows and
lastly them boys at prepper thanks for helping us
edit down these highlights let's get to it people
no
don't point that pipe in my mom
stop making noise guys
losing your rain advantage
come on dude at this point
ah
surrender come on
no what the [ __ ] no oh that's
messed up you couldn't oh dang
oh yes finally crossed paths
the hero
now she's so goddamn focused secure
the perimeter then family reunion
she gonna forget what you did nope
oh
it's crawling around out there
somewhere i'm there you guys ball god
run away why oh ho ho ho
no
roundhouse kick all their face
no dude no
oh no oh my god no oh oh sacrifice himself
respect all that time dedicated is saving his ass
maybe he'll come back as a humber
guinea got swarmed
no no
there's two down
you're still alive not for long
instant karma
oh i feel fellow bad for
you tan oh and there it is
unless this guy finds now we got
two down oh come on come back
oh wow
she had like sores all over her face
that is not the information that we're hoping for
yep that's what i was afraid of ugh
um
the way to find out if they're
actually infected is just feed them
human food and if they don't react negatively
to it they're fine it's a good call actually
i think this dude's gonna get turned into a zombie
pick up some christmas presents along the way
damn you guys got to get some food
um
[ __ ] feel it
goddamn korean troubles
ha ha
no
probably some protective
gear in here too somewhere
oh
i need more eyeballs
you guys must have excelled
in your arts and crafts
i know what the nis is
i would have eaten that [ __ ] in
i secret covet still exists in this world yeah
guys you don't have any rapid antigen tests
i thought he was last year
we should go low
you know i mean you're gonna be fine you
don't need any pads donate them to the group
that is some creative ass [ __ ] right there
oh man god that would be so freaking terrifying
throw some balls
one of you has to bait them away
yeah he's used to it by now he's
falling off way higher things
there it goes he knew they were
focusing he didn't even get to eat
oh he will now i'll bait them away
then man get on that box bait them away
poor guy there you go
come on man get some distance
no oh man that guy really sacrificed it
all yeah maybe he'll be rewarded as a hamby
oh man sorry [ __ ] no oh just turn
my already
you knew that was coming
oh [ __ ] dang
why would you walk into a
building without a weapon prepared
oh she sees her looking right past her
what is this guy's scent ability
she can open it yeah
god damn it
oh my god don't get bit holy crap please turn
the [ __ ] around holy crap please turn around
what for real
oh yeah i guess it's fine thank god yeah
it's going to get bit right out yeah
don't worry the next episode will start and then
he'll get finished junior got the short end of
the stick this episode man didn't even get to eat
had a final meal before going right down death row
came up with the plan well yeah that was a good
episode man it's thrilling i'm glad we finally
got the convergence of the two groups it's like
watching al pacino and robert de niro finally
cross pass and he more closer to a superhero movie
like when finally these superhero characters get
interact where they're like bickering at first
and they're fighting they're not getting along
before eventually they gotta work together as
a unit that's more along the lines of what it
was that was good [ __ ] man [ __ ] confessing to
the archer girl oh this feeling that's such a good
scene i love the smoker trick that's how i always
identified her is yeah she's she's so fun she's
she's one of my favorites for sure to come out
of this i like the shades of her character yeah
because like she's so good at putting up the front
but then in the moments of true intensity you see
beyond that vernier and i think she's really good
at playing that yeah she's a caring woman yeah
very much so very much so and even with um chong's
son man yeah watching how he had to deal with the
death of his mom it must really stop you in your
tracks whenever it's someone you actually know i
would have to imagine yeah i mean because there's
all that i feel like no amount of zombie movie
logic will prepare you for when your time comes
to see the relative turn their head and oh no but
i really like the way they handle that i like the
way he's like in shock basically throughout that
and slowly has to kind of be brought back into
the room and i mean like it totally makes sense
and yeah it was like really heartbreaking
like this was such an intense episode
for so many reasons and one of them was just
like emotional intensity just like so many
this is this might have been like one of the more
tear-jerkery episodes just because of how painful
some of the situations become especially i didn't
cry once oh well you know it's just because you
have a heart of stone yeah i never cried once
during the show you've never cried in any show
i got a little emotional when you young died
just because he was like saying let's go home
yeah let's go home well at homegirl like calling
out for a mom like things like that yeah i'm just
like oh like especially in a death moment where
someone starts to say something that you know
they won't ever get to experience or they won't
it won't come true for them like that's a device
that works very well on me yeah it's really
harrowing and desperate love it good stuff all
around man i think the way they really i like the
nighttime rain action sequence probably the most
and that's great this military operation
man i don't blame them for what they
got to do i don't either if i was not in
these kids shoes yeah if i was just like in the
quarantine zone and i heard like hey people and
i saw i think hi son hyo sam hyo-san um take it
from me a white guy you're probably closer than me
uh from heroes on from people over there i'm like
oh they're breaking through and that's where this
all started and you know it's pretty bad like
they're not really finding any people alive yeah
and like the military's thinking of bombing and
i'd be like [ __ ] vomit you're gonna contain this
thing man whatever it costs i want to live think
of how many lives save the rest of korea and the
world i don't think i'd be a good person about
the whole thing of course i'd like to fantasize
and be like no go in there save people okay
craig you're going to come with us oh [ __ ] no
no no i'm not going to what are you crazy i
got my life in line use my resources for that
yeah for sure yeah so i i get the um the idea it's
like the way they presented they br sometimes the
people who are so tactical about it come across
so cold that the show kind of sometimes depending
on the character they're focusing on i would not
say like the the main military general guy doesn't
seem like a bad person to me but the there's like
sort of the political figures or i'm like you
seem like a total cold-hearted [ __ ] about it oh
the head of the party guy coming in the beginning
of the episode to be like here i'll protect your
career to the end man just you guys got to resign
yeah yeah so all that being said you know
it's again a battle of perspectives and
that's greenhouse guy it's just something else
i'm just like what the hell what is this like
insane werewolf dog sniffing ability you come from
like how far away is this yeah there's this trail
you picked up on it feels like his fault or even
scent of their travel is that what was going on
yeah and i mean namra has that too but it seems
like we nom is like smelling them from like
miles away well i think the show plays it like
he smelled them from miles away but i think he
was just picking up on a trail of where they
were running that probably or or maybe even
the sound too like he's trying the sound i mean
you know but vibrations are creating a sentence
but yeah no i feel like there
was a moment there where it
kind of got overlapped to me where it's like he's
sniffing around but you also hear like the banging
on the door and stuff so yeah i couldn't tell if
he was just trying to sniff them out or not or who
knows maybe the wind patterns you know or blowing
down wind and if everything smells dead and then
only a few people smell alive maybe there's
that but this is the highest death count of the
characters we've actually hung out with in a while
at least i don't know what the actual tally is but
i think in a while because we got like at least
three yeah homeboy sacrificed himself at the top
and then uh jun young at the end and then
homegirl on the on the way he sacrificed
himself the guy who they were wheeling around
whining whose only character beat was to wine
until that one moment where he actually you know
bought them some time and did something heroic
yeah but still but i liked how the revelation
came out of our smoker girl yeah how in that
moment she was you know she always been
such a [ __ ] to him in that final moment
of just he was like i don't care no we're gonna
and she was fighting to save him no matter what
yeah some really great character beats this
episode and like there's a lot of yeah it's
like we lost more people in the immediate you
know focus than we have in a few episodes and
we also got to counterbalance that some nice
like heartfelt moments like i really liked uh
daisu is that his name the guy like him
confessing his uh his uh infatuation to uh
cool archer girl and all that she's the
mvp no i'm runner i could walk out of this
dude if they if them two teamed up
they're unstoppable just back to back
well i think non-restaurant as powerful as him
because she hasn't fed that makes a lot of sense
yeah or she's feeding whenever he can on anything
and everything it's like she knows she's a zombie
yeah she's fully aware she's just trying to be
as logical and rational as she can despite that
well i like these sequences when they get like
crafty and like really get creative together to
solve their way out of a situation yeah and
they gotta build something or they gotta yeah
like that's that's been a nice thing it's like oh
these kids are either already capable or they're
good at at least looking at their environment
and and coming up with something you know
which is funny enough i i feel like i'm not used
to seeing as much and granted not as many zombie
things that you see regularly are this ensemble
driven so like the whole point is there is like
a team that you can rely upon but it's been really
nice to have it feel like we just got these found
objects you know we don't have like weapons galore
to uh to rely upon so yeah it's just got to be wit
and and two things like that like i like they
put you in their shoes like when they're all
voting and deciding on how to build the thing
i'm like yeah i don't really know what would be
the best way i guess building up high seems
smarter than building low but who's to say
yeah yeah it's good it's well well-worn i think
it would be stupid to have built it low because
if they all got on top it would be really
difficult to move it like they could barely
move it when they're standing yeah it's it
would be they wouldn't be able to move it at all
barricaded better yeah but they would
definitely be able to they wouldn't be
able to push that [ __ ] no yeah probably
any any covering they put on top would
probably be crushed under the weight of
so many just bodies trying to get in yeah
i think they ultimately did the right thing
um so my predictions are jung-sun's gonna die
i think he i think this show keeps
hinting that he's gonna die okay i think
i think that firefighter guy dad is still gonna
die okay all the men in her life are going to die
and then anjo is going to
be the the remainder and uh
that's all i got but the other ones i hate the
other ones i'm like ah we'll see yeah yeah in
terms of major debts i'm feeling like those two
definitely are gonna die um jury's out still
for me on chung-sun but i think i think the dad is
going to ultimately make some kind of sacrifice or
yeah be taken it's going to be reward enough that
they get reunited at all there's going to be a
a thing that like it's a good thing he showed up
so she could live yes and so that she could at
least have that one last bit that so many of them
don't get which is you know okay i got to see my
parent figure again so i don't feel quite so
alone when i have to go out on my own true
be without them we'll see how it all
unfolds just two more episodes left
guys leave your thoughts down below
hit that like button last but not least
daniel gallacher my friend if the [ __ ] ever
hit the fan you would be in a prime position dude
what because you're scottish and if anybody knows
the best fighters in the world it's the scots
all right you would be taking down zombies left
and right bare knuckle boxing them with your abs
rippling pecs bulging you're not even getting
bit like zombies just hanging off your arm by
the teeth but you are just sitting there the teeth
break off on your bulging muscles and then when
you finally reach civilization everyone's gonna
be like what is this guy we have to synthesize
a steroid out of his blood and then from there
you'll be a patient zero of a whole other variety
turning mankind into super beings so daniel live
through the apocalypse my friend i have no doubt
that you will and we'll catch you next month
hope your 2022 is going good that wasn't bad
wasn't bad right i already won the pharmacy wrap
good job thanks man i did my best to not do that
you